- [Kelly] I do know the
things that you do love,
which I love.
- Yeah.
- I love reading.
I know that you love reading
as well.
- Yes, I do.
- But I heard you just got into studying
extraterrestrial life.
- Yeah.
- Okay,
I think this is interesting too.
Especially what's going on now.
- So do you-, what do you think?
What do you think?
- Well, here's the deal.
Someone showed some video of Trump,
Clinton,
Obama,
- What?
- asking them
what about extraterrestrials
at different interviews
and they're all like,
well, they're hedging it.
Even Trump who's like (blows raspberry)
he'll say anything.
They're hedging it, so
they know something.
- Oh
- There's something.
There is something out there.
- There's definitely something out there.
- First of all, we are one planet.
A tiny one at that.
- Yeah.
- In a huge galaxy.
In an infinite universe.
There has to be
life somewhere else.
- I just-
- Of course, humanity's
like, we're the only ones.
- I know. It's kind of crazy.
- I'm like, it's so egocentric.
It's like, yeah.
- I think that that's
a quality of humanity
and I think they're all watching us
laughing and crying at the same time.
- Yeah.
- Because we do, we kind
of have this selfishness
and we can't see past our own boundaries.
- Yeah.
- But we're like this.
- Or we think it's gonna be like us.
It might be something
completely different.
Yeah
- That's- I think that's-
- It probably is.
- But these two things
that they just shot down,
and I'm not talking about
the Chinese spy balloon,
but the two other things
that they shot down
were unmanned.
So, I don't know.
I mean, they still haven't said what it is
and, you know, area 51 did not go away.
It became something else
that became even more classified.
So...
- Wouldn't it be funny though
if it was just some
hillbilly in like Texas,
just like, I'm gonna put this up there
(Jane and audience laughs)
and see what happens.
- Could be.
- People are like, it's aliens.
- Yes, exactly.
(Kelly laughs)
- Some people say that
these things we're seeing as aliens
are really angels.
- Oh.
- Some say that,
that it's, you know
and they're trying to help us.
- I'm into the option of everything
- You're what?
- Good luck. (Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, right, I know, I know.
- I'm open to everything.
- I am too.
I think everything is a possibility
because you don't know.
I think it's,
- Yeah.
- I think it's just very
arrogant to go I know.
- Well, you know, contempt
prior to investigation
is what I think stops people
from actually opening up their mind.
- And also I tend to be kind of
airy fairy and into that stuff.
- Me too.
- Yeah, I'm kind of
- Why not?
- an easy mark.
- I'm such an easy mark too.
(Jane laughs)
I probably own the books you're reading.